>>> COULD CONGRESS BAN
CRYPTOCURRENCY?
LAWMAKERS COULD FACE PRESSURE TO
MAKE IT ILLEGAL IN THE U.S.
HERE'S THE SENATE BANKING
CHAIRMAN SHERROD BROWN THIS
MORNING RESPONDING TO THE
SUGGESTION CONGRESS SHOULD
OUTLAW THE DIGITAL CURRENCY.
>> I SHARE THAT THOUGHT ALTHOUGH
BANNING IT IS VERY DIFFICULT
BECAUSE IT WILL GO OFFSHORE.
THIS IS A COMPLICATED,
UNREGULATED POT OF MONEY.
>> LET'S DISCUSS THIS WITH
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN FRENCH
HILL OF ARKANSAS, A MEMBER OF
THE FINANCIAL SERVICES COMMITTEE
AND AN A-RATING FROM A PRO
CRYPTO LOBBYING GROUP.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE?
SHOULD CONGRESS CONSIDER BANNING
CRYPTO ALTOGETHER?
>> IT IS GOOD TO BE WITH YOU.
MERRY CHRISTMAS AND HAPPY FIRST
NIGHT OF HANUKKAH.
WE SHOULDN'T THROW THE BABY OUT
WITH THE BATH WATER.
ACCOMPANIED BY A DIGITAL PAYMENT
IS SOMETHING THAT WE WANT TO SEE
THAT INNOVATION IN THE UNITED
STATES AND LED BY U.S. COMPANIES
AND INNOVATORS SO I CAN'T BE A
FAN OF BANNING CRYPTOCURRENCY IN
THE U.S.
I THINK WE NEED AN EFFECTIVE
DEFINITION AND REGULATORY SYSTEM
TO BENEFIT THE U.S. AND
INVESTORS AND BLOCKCHAIN.
>> AS YOU PROBABLY KNOW ACTOR
BENJAMIN McKENZIE TESTIFIED ON
THE HILL CALLING CRYPTOCURRENCY
THE LARGEST PONZI SCHEME IN
HISTORY.
WHAT WOULD YOU TELL A FAMILY
MEMBER THAT WANTS TO INVEST IN
CRYPTOCURRENCY?
>> IT IS AN UNRELATED MARKET
WITH A LOT OF FRAUDSTERS
ENGAGED.
THIS IS THE 14th ANNIVERSARY OF
THE BERNIE MADOFF FRAUD IN THE
NEWS AND NOW FTX I THINK WILL
DWARF ANYTHING THAT MADOFF DID
WRONG WITH OVER A MILLION
CREDITORS SO I WOULD NOT
RECOMMEND PEOPLE INVEST IN
CRYPTOCURRENCY IF THEY DON'T
HAVE THE MONEY TO RISK BECAUSE I
DON'T THINK IT'S A CLEAR AND
WELL REGULATED MARKET.
IT IS AN EXPERIMENT AND
SOPHISTICATED PEOPLE THEMSELVES
GAVE MONEY TO FTX AND LOST THAT
MONEY.
>> RIGHT.
BUT WHAT ABOUT OVERSIGHT THEN?
IS CONGRESS GOING TO DO MORE TO
CRACK DOWN?
>> TWO COMMENTS THERE.
ONE I THINK THERE ARE EXISTING
SECURITIES LAWS AND COMMODITIES
LAWS THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN PUT
IN PLACE AND COULD HAVE DONE
MORE TO PROTECT INVESTORS VETO
FTX.
CONGRESS I BELIEVE YOU WILL SEE
A BIPARTISAN EFFORT TO DEFINE A
DIGITAL ASSET AND WE HAVE MADE
STRIDES AT THAT THIS FALL WITH
WORK BY MAXINE WATERS WITH
McHENRY OF NORTH CAROLINA TO
REGULATE STABLE COINS.
>> I WANT TO TURN TO KEVIN
McCARTHY.
IT'S STILL A LOT UP IN THE AIR
FOR NEXT MONTH WHEN REPUBLICANS
HAVE THE MAJORITY OF THE HOUSE.
MIKE GALLAGHER OF WISCONSIN SAID
THAT REPUBLICANS WILL GET THERE
ON KEVIN McCARTHY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
DO YOU THINK HE CAN GET THE 218
VOTES HE NEEDS CONSIDERING 5
VOTES SAID THEY OPPOSE HIM?
>> KEVIN McCARTHY WON A SECRET
BALLOT IN THE REPUBLICAN
CONFERENCE 85% TO BE NOMINATED
AS SPEAKER ELECT.
HE WORKED TIRELESSLY TO RECRUIT
GOOD CANDIDATES, TO DEFINE THE
AGENDA IN THE AMERICAN
COMMITMENT TO AMERICA AND
DESERVES A SHOT AND I PLAN TO
SUPPORT HIM.
I THINK HE'LL GET THERE.
>> OKAY.
ANOTHER ISSUE OR CRISIS AT THE
BORDER, OFFICIALS ARE PREPARING
FOR A SURGE OF MIGRANTS ON
WEDNESDAY.
REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN QUICK TO
PIN THIS CRISIS ON PRESIDENT
BIDEN BUT KEISHA LANCE BOTTOMS
SAID THE ONUS IS ON CONGRESS TO
FIND A SOLUTION.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS SAID HE
WANTS TO GET THINGS DONE IN A
BIPARTISAN MANNER.
REPUBLICANS WILL CONTROL THE
HOUSE SO THE NEED OF REPUBLICANS
IN CONGRESS TO SAY WHAT THEY
WON'T DO IS REMOVED.
TELL US WHAT YOU WILL DO TO WORK
WITH THE PRESIDENT TO HAVE
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM.
>> WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THAT,
CONGRESSMAN?
>> IN 2018 REPUBLICANS PUT
COMPREHENSIVE REFORM --
>> 41 REPUBLICANS VOTED AGAINST
THAT.
>> TRUE.
BUT THAT'S A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT CONGRESS.
WE HAD LEADERSHIP TO DEVELOP IN
COMMITTEE REFORM AND BORDER
SECURITY.
WE DIDN'T GET THE SUPPORT FROM
THE DEMOCRATS ON THAT AND NO
SUPPORT FROM PRESIDENT BIDEN
SINCE HE WAS SWORN INTO OFFICE
AND DID AWAY WITH THE TRUMP
POLICIES THAT WERE WORKING AND
DIDN'T REPLACE THEM WITH
ANYTHING.
THAT'S WHAT'S DISAPPOINTING TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
UNSAFE STREETS.
FENTANYL.
RECORD AMOUNTS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IN THE COUNTRY.
I THINK REPUBLICANS DO HAVE
CONCRETE, SPECIFIC PROPOSALS TO
REFORM IMMIGRATION AND SECURE
THE BORDER.
>> LOOK.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS BOTH
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS SAY IT
IS A PROBLEM.
NOTHING IS DONE.
BOTH HAVE BEEN MAJORITIES IN
CONGRESS AND BEEN IN THE WHITE
HOUSE.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR.
ON THE FENTANYL ASPECT AND SO
FORTH, THAT IS A COMMON TALKING
POINT, THE FENTANYL AT LEGAL
POINTS OF ENTRY FROM AMERICAN
CITIZENS SO I WANT TO POINT THAT
OUT.
WHAT WOULD YOU DO AS A
REPUBLICAN IN THE MAJORITY IN
THE HOUSE?
WHAT SPECIFICALLY WOULD YOU DO?
>> FIRST I'VE BEEN TO THE BORDER
SEVEN TIMES IN SEVEN AND A HALF
YEARS LISTENING TO AGENTS AND
JUDGES AND LISTENING TO ON THE
GROUND PRECISELY WHAT WE SHOULD
DO.
HERE'S WHAT THEY TELL ME.
THEY WOULD TELL THE PRESIDENT IF
HE WOULD SHOW UP AND LISTEN.
ENFORCE THE EXISTING IMMIGRATION
LAWS WHY NOT DEPORTING FELONS IN
THE COUNTRY ILLEGALLY AT THE
SAME RATE AT PRESIDENT OBAMA.
NOT ENFORCING THE PROCESS
CORRECTLY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP MADE PROPOSALS
TO DO THAT.
DO THAT.
NEXT ADJUDGES.
WE ADDED JUDGES IN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
NEED TO ADJUDICATE THE CASES.
AMEND THE IMMIGRATION LAWS AND
RECOMMEND FOR EXAMPLE THE
DEFINITION OF CREDIBLE FEAR TO
BE FINE TUNED THERE AND THEN
BUILD THE BORDER SECURITY THAT
THE BORDER PATROL RECOMMENDS AND
WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP TRIED TO DO
IN THE FIGHT OVER THE BORDER
WALL AND PRESIDENT BIDEN STOPPED
BUILDING IT.
WE ARE STILL PAYING FOR JIT
THERE'S CONCRETE PROPOSALS BUT
THE ADMINISTRATION SHOULD GO TO
THE BORDER AND LISTEN TO THE
PEOPLE WHOSE JOB IT IS TO SECURE
IT FOR THOSE BEST
RECOMMENDATIONS.
>> THE PART ABOUT STILL PAYING
FOR IT WE NEED A FACT CHECK
THERE BUT I WANT TO MOVE ON
BECAUSE GOVERNOR OF ARKANSAS
SAID TODAY THIS MORNING THAT HE
IS SERIOUSLY CONSIDERING A 2024
RUN FOR THE WHITE HOUSE.
AND THEN YOU HAVE REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR TOOMEY WHO YOU WORKED
CLOSELY WITH WEIGHING IN ON THE
FUTURE OF THE GOP.
>> I HEARD FROM MANY, MANY VERY
PRO TRUMP VOTERS THAT THINK
THINK IT IS TIME FOR THE PARTY
TO MOVE ON.
I THINK THAT PROCESS IS
UNDERWAY.
NOT A FLIP OF A SWITCH.
HE STILL HAS A SIGNIFICANT
FOLLOWING.
BUT I DO THINK HIS INFLUENCE IS
WANING.
>> IN YOUR DISTRICT YOU GET THE
SENSE THAT PEOPLE WANT A
DIFFERENT LEADER THAN FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP?
>> HERE IN ARKANSAS IT IS A VERY
RED STATE AND I THINK PEOPLE ARE
WANTING REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP IN
2024.
WHAT I HAVE HEARD IS THEY ARE
OPEN MINDED ABOUT THAT.
MANY OF THE SUPPORTERS IN MY
DISTRICT ARE ATTRACTED TO
GOVERNOR DESANTIS.
GOVERNOR HUTCHINSON HAS
SUPPORTERS.
WE HAVE TALENTED REPUBLICANS TO
RUN FOR THE 2024 PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION AND I THINK THAT
PROCESS IS WELL UNDERWAY AS WE
TURN THE NEW YEAR.
>> WOULD YOU LIKE TO SEE ONE OF
THOSE --
>> I THINK BOTH PARTIES OUGHT TO
NOT RENOMINATE DONALD TRUMP AND
JOE BIDEN.
IT WOULD BE GOOD FOR THE COUNTRY
FOR A NEW DIRECTION AND WE HAVE
A TALENTED REPUBLICAN BENCH.
>> I ALSO WANT TO CIRCLE BACK.
WE ARE STICK LERS FOR FACTS.
ON THE IMMIGRATION FRONT IN JULY
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION DID
ALLOW FUNDS TO CLOSE THE BORDER
WALL IN ARIZONA, PARTS.
ANNOUNCED PLANS TO DO THAT.
FINAL WORDS FROM YOU --
>> THAT'S A TEENIE TINY JUST FOR
POLITICAL PURPOSES BEFORE THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
THERE ARE HUXS OF MILES FUNDED
TO BE BUILT THAT AREN'T BEING
BUILT.
THAT'S